Muy bien, bienvenidos de nuevo al banco de armas. Hoy será el segundo episodio.
Vamos a montar
el Smith & Wesson SD-9.
Es otro kit bastante económico y fácil de conseguir,
ya sea en Every Gun Part o en GunBroker.
Hoy tengo aquí un armazón impreso en azul translúcido.
Creo que es de Sunloo.
Hace años, nunca habríamos usado un filamento translúcido, pero la ciencia de los filamentos ha
avanzado muchísimo desde entonces, y este material viene en rojo, azul y transparente, creo, y tal vez
uno o dos colores más, y es bastante resistente. Así que estoy muy impreso con él.
Ya saben, no es para todo el mundo, pero aguanta muy bien. No es como el nailon de fibra de carbono.
Este no es el tipo de armazón que puedes dejar en la guantera
durante el verano, pero bueno, es llamativo y está bien para usar en el campo de tiro o
para tenerlo en la mesita de noche. En fin,
así que sí, vamos a montar esta arma, así que empecemos.
Sí, esto es solo un trozo de alambre de piano, coloca el retén impreso,
toma el alambre de piano y deslízalo en su lugar.
Realmente necesita bajar un poco más. Ahí está. Veamos si podemos hacer que encaje. Muy bien, perfecto.
Muy bien, para poder
montar uno de estos SD, vas a necesitar esto. Esto es un
Riel SD.
Ese riel de Riptide se vende. Así que el riel clausesero está integrado en el conjunto del sear trasero.
Y por eso
cuando pides esto a Riptide,
va en el bolsillo pitcherero de este worksheet de aquí, y se instala con un pasador
de tres milímetros que viene con él.
Si tienes problemas para colocarlos, algo que aprendí es que puedes tomar estos confinementadores. Puedes fundamentallyirlos
en una lima.
Solo en la punta para darle un ligero chaflán y
eso ayuda a que encuentre su camino.
La mayoría de las veces, traen un pequeño redondeo, pero es,
ya sabes, es bastanteAndrew kdy.
Muy bien, ahora vamos a poner
este bloque del sear trasero. Vamos a poner este confinementador trasero.
El confinementador del sear es el que parece un confinementadorAndrew de presión. Es hueco por el medio.
A diferencia del confinementador del worksheet que es sólido.
Sí, voy a tener que darle un poco de golpe a ese. Noté antes que estaba unżaito apretado.
Hay que tener cuidado, pero nunca está de más usar un martillo
duro con algunos de estos.
Je. Voy a tener que salir de cámara un segundo. Todavía estoy ajustando los detalles de la cámara.
Así que instalas este pasador de rodillo.
Ahora es el momento del grupo del disparador y el bloque de cierre.
Así que
deberás tener en cuenta un par de cosas.
Sí, Smith & Wesson, es muy gracioso. Han mantenido este
diseño arcaico del resorte del disparador justo aquí.
Lo que tendrás que hacer es que, al poner esto, tendrás que pasar el pasador del disparador no solo por el,
ya sabes, retén de la corredera y el bloque de cierre, sino que también tendrás que pasarlo por ese anillo.
Si no tienes mucho cuidado con eso y, ya sabes, lo fuerzas a la fuerza,
puedes destruir ese anillo y tendrás que comprar otro resorte.
Así que, ya sabes, es bueno que al menos vigiles lo que haces en ese sentido.
Este pequeño gancho simplemente rodea esta
parte trasera, así.
Vamos a meter esto y luego tomaremos este
retén de la corredera
y básicamente lo deslizaremos junto al disparador, debajo del bloque de cierre.
Normalmente, lo que me gusta hacer es intentar usar un punzón ahí
para que todo quede alineado.
Es especialmente crítico con ese anillo.
Sí, eso es
Así que tengo un..., y esto podría, esto podría funcionar de verdad.
Es solo un trozo de alambre musical. Lo que intento hacer
es intentar alinear ese anillo para poder atravesar el medio, casi.
Ahí está. Muy bien, ahora está alineado, pero no es perfecto.
Así que lo que voy a hacer es empezar con este pasador del disparador.
No marca una gran diferencia, pero técnicamente esa
ranura debería ir en el lado del retén de la corredera. Está hecha para enganchar ese
resorte y normalmente puedes empujar esto. No sé si puedes verlo, pero el anillo del resorte está
alrededor de mi pasador del disparador.
Probablemente no se vea bien porque el enfoque no es muy bueno, pero eso es lo que hay que buscar.
Y luego puedes, oh, no he logrado pasarlo por el retén de la corredera.
No pasa nada.
Un poco más. Sí, ahí está.
Muy bien, creo que ya está.
Sí, eso es un poco complicado. El resorte de alambre está empujando el retén de la corredera hacia abajo,
así que está desalineado en ese orificio. Así que tienes que, ya sabes, hay un par de formas de hacerlo,
pero si logras que roce un poco el extremo de ese pasador en el lado opuesto, puedes
como hice yo con ese punzón, hacer palanca hacia arriba. Se queda ahí
lo suficiente como para que puedas
empujar el pasador hacia adelante.
El último paso será, antes de instalar la corredera,
es el...
Jaja. Será el resorte.
Oh sí, aquí vamos.
Así que esto, vale, el resorte que viene con esto es como
uno de esos resortes de lámina plana.
Este usa, ya sabes, básicamente como, no sé, ¿qué es?, un resorte
helicoidal de Gen 5.
Este es un ejemplo muy deformado de uno
porque es lo que tenía por aquí.
Y funcionaba, pero está bastante deformado y, ya sabes, funciona, pero no está bien.
Así que lo que voy a hacer es empujarlo hacia el
hueco y luego deslizaremos esto sobre el resorte.
Hay un reborde aquí en esta palanca de desmontaje que apunta
hacia la parte trasera del arma. Si esto apunta hacia el lado equivocado,
el cañón no va a encajar
cuando la corredera cierre. Intentará saltar sobre esto. Así que
lo que hacemos es empezar por encima del resorte y
con un destornillador pequeño lo empujas para que asiente el borde. Ahí está. Y luego
sí, lo colocas en su sitio.
Y una vez que hagamos eso, podremos poner esto
solo como un comentario. Estos son convertibles para funcionar con
estos son lo suficientemente cercanos como para que puedas convertirlos para que funcionen en Glock Lowers.
Tengo una guía para hacer eso y lo haremos algún día.
Y ahí lo tienen.
Eso es un
Glock Mag SD9. Esos kits, ya sabes, suelen costar unos cien dólares, tal vez un poco menos.
No son tan baratos como las pistolas SR, pero ya sabes, si estás atento, puedes encontrar una oferta.
Y
ya sabes, son buenas pistolas.
En fin,
espero que hayan disfrutado esto. Nos vemos la próxima vez.